- Avant de répondre à la
Je suis, je viens de...
Oui Monifaith, toitutu viens
d'où?
- Je viens du Cameroun.
- Je viens des Philippines.
- Je m'alelele Matvii.
Je viens d'Ukraine. s s s s s s?
- Dansclclclasse!
- Dans la classe!e e e e e e e t
rararancisation, Olivier Kenfack
bouge beaucoup.
OLIVIER KENFACK,s.s.s.s.s.s.s.sn
- Je mime, on fait des mimes.
On prend des situations
authentiques, vous l'avez vu.
Je fais comme du théâ...........
En cinq années, j'ai eu
une clientèle difntntnte au fil
du temps. Cette année, c'est
beaucoup plus diversifié.
- Avec la mê un plus grand
nombre d'élèves arrivés comme
demandeurssisisile.
- Il y en a vraiment qui ontuau:
la genenenen Ukraine, les
transits par d'autres pays.
Ils viennent par ls s s s s s ss
ont vecu des traumas, ils ne
s'adaptent pas facilement.
Je dois d'abord créer un lien
affectif. Ilcececececececececec.
Tu prends le Bescherelle,
si tu en as de besoin!
- Cette école de Côte-des-Neige.
On y enseigne leaiaiaiais
aux nouveaux arrivants depuis ya
maintenantuvuvuvuveaux défis.
NATHALIE BLANCHET, directrice,-n
- Je ce e e e quand même
d'énormes différences entre ce
que j'avais connu et la réalité
tetetetete année particulièreme.
Il y a eu une pause dûe à
la pandémie, mais là on setrtrts
qui doivent quitter leur pays
parce qu'ils ne peuvent plus
rester. Alors là, on
des familles qui arrivent
et qui ont besoin de tout.
Il y a eu des interruptions dans
la scolarisation, ils arrivent
avec rien, souvent juste avec
un petit sac. Alors, bien,
il faut trouver des sacs
à dos, il faut s'occuper de la
nourriture, comment il vont
manger.
- Pour inscrire les enfants à
l'école, les nouveaux arrivants
doivent avoir une adresse fixe.,
au Canada.
- Arrivé du Brésil en août avec
quatre enfants, Valery Valbrune
espère que ses filles puissent
enfin commencer l'école
au Québec.
MATHIEU DESJARDINS, dir. service
organisation scolaire, CSSDM
- La grande majorité de
nos nouvelles inscriptions,
c'est des demandeurs d'asile.
Les pays qu'on a le plus
présentement c'est le Mexique,
c'est la Colombie, c'est Haïti
et l'Ukraine. Donc, c'est
des pays où on a des demandeurs
d'asiles soit par le chemin
Roxham ou des demandeurs d'asile
Ukrainiens.
- Le service des inscriptions
du Centre de service scolaire
de Montréal, le plus gra
Québec, est occupé comme jamais.
En deux mois, 1500 nouveaux
élèves se sont ajoutés.
Un record en si pe
- 82 classes, c'est l'équivalent
d'une centaine d'enseignants
qu'on doit trouver.
Mais au niveurururururururie
de personnel, c'est ce qui
nous inquiète le plus. Chaque
nouvelle inscription nous
demande e e e e e e nouvelles
classes. Donc, on n'a plus
de place dans les classes
existantes, donc ça allongeusus.
- Depuis quelques années,
le CSSDM a une équipe d'employés
dédiée au soutien des familleset
qui donne aussi un appui
au personnel des écoles.
RÉGINALD FLEURY, conseil pédago.
relations intercult., CSSDM
- On peut pas prévoir a moyen
ou à court trerme qu'il va
y avoir une baisse de
la population scolaire
immigrante, donc c'est vraiment
des forces qu'on est en train
de se construire pour les années
à venir.
- Est-ce que c'est une phrase
simple ou une phrase complexe?
- À Saint-Pascal-Baylon,
l'accueil va bie
de l'école grâce à des agents
de service social comme
Rim Bouallegue. Dans l'église
voisine, des parents viennent
choisis s s s s s s s s chauds.
-On parle des besoins de base.
On parle de dépannage
vestimentaire, mais on peut
aller au-delà.
usususususususususe ressource
veille aussi sur ceux qui
doivent encore attendre avant
de pouvoir fréquenter l'école.
RIM BOUALLdedededededededede
service social, CSSDM
- On a reçu 35 demandeurs
d'asile d'origine Kurde.
C'étquququququququququi est
dans les hôtels depuis quatre
mois qui n'arrivent pas
trouver de logement, doncriririr
les enfants. Et on a reussi
nous, au centre de services
scolaires de préparer avecllèlls
pédagogiques à l'accueil,
une trousse avec des outils
simples, avec
pour ces enfants.
- Et avec l'aide de Rim aussi,
c'est beauouououououououououour
moi parce que par le passé je ne
l'avais pas. Mais ce qu'il
manqrerererererererereressources
au sein de l'école.
- Après avoir enseigné au
opopopopopopopopopope pendant
des années, monsieur Olivier
prend le temps qu'il faut avecle
l'accueil.
- Ce sont des élèves qui
arrivent avec des bagages. a a s
baggages d'abord linguistiques
et culturels. Je m'appuie sur
celui-là pour mettre une couche.
- Allo!
- Ici Anne-Louise Despatie,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
- Bo